foreign
in the coming decades my generation of
Millennials and genzeers will inherit
the largest amount of wealth Humanity
has ever created some 30 trillion
dollars
that's a huge wallet
unluckily for us we'll also inherit some
huge issues climate change geopolitical
instability inequality what we choose to
do or not do with this enormous wallet
will Define the future of our species
no pressure folks
why might you ask am I talking about my
generation's wallet
well the reason why is because I'm an
investor and the essence of my job is to
allocate your savings to build a better
future
because I'm also a millennial who
doesn't particularly like losing sleep
over the thought of rising global
temperatures my job also requires me to
think about what's good for society
and from where I sit one of the keys to
bettering the world is ESG investing
ESG stands for environmental social and
governance think of ESG as additional
little pieces of data that some
investors consider when analyzing the
risks or opportunities of an investment
so for example a car company that starts
selling more electric vehicles may be
around longer in a future where we can't
burn as many fossil fuels so an investor
might consider that company to be a
safer place to put your money
in an Ideal World
here's what ESG promises
it promises better investment returns
because money is invested in companies
with sustainable practices which makes
them likelier to be around longer term
it promises Business Leaders who share
more and better data about what their
companies are doing
it promises greater productivity by
allocating money to companies that
maintain strong relationships with
customers employees and suppliers
that's the vision
the good news is that some people
younger Generations especially have
started buying into this vision and ESG
strategies have gained a ton of momentum
over the past years
that's the good news hashtag happy
the not so good news is that we're still
far away from achieving the full
Promises of ESG
here's a sobering fact
a recent survey from Callan a major
investment consulting firm suggests that
about half of institutional investors
consider the benefits of ESG to be
unclear or unproven in other words many
of the people who will allocate
Millennials and genzir's money aren't
fully convinced that ESG is relevant
when deciding where to put your money
now I think there are many reasons why
this might be the case for example
investors focused on short-term outcomes
might not necessarily know the best way
to consider longer-term sustainability
or there may be a sense that companies
can't do well and do good at the same
time
whatever the reason may be this is a
problem folks if the people running the
investment strategies don't anticipate
ESG will work
how can we achieve its full promises
the key word in all of this is expect
let me now tell you something I didn't
fully appreciate until I started working
in finance
we'd all like to think that investment
decisions are made with cold hard data
and nothing else but the truth is that
investors are people and the economy is
made of people which means that like it
or not a lot of what happens in
financial markets comes down to
psychology and expectations and these
expectations can be a force for good or
bad
John Maynard Keynes one of the fathers
of modern economics once famously
described how powerful expectations or
animal spirits as he called them can
play a powerful role in markets
he also had a pretty sweet mustache
anyway I digress the point is that I've
seen the power of what expectations can
do and here's a firsthand example I'm
from Venezuela and in the late 20 teens
my home country experienced one of the
worst periods of hyperinflation ever
recorded now there were many reasons why
this hyperinflation took place and I
won't go into all of them here but among
those reasons was a concept called
inflation expectations
what inflation expectations basically
means is that when people believe prices
in the future will go up that belief
that animal spirit can literally cause
prices to rise today
expectations create reality
so coming back to ESG what Venezuelan
Lord Keynes have taught me is that
making ESG and sustainability mainstream
will require us to literally redefine
society's expectations of what ESG is
and what it can do that might sound like
a tall order but I think there's a few
things you and I can do about it
one solution investors are working on is
to standardize ESG metrics so for
context right now there are lots of
Divergent opinions about what metrics
matter most or are material and in the
middle of this analysis paralysis
because there's a million things we
could be measuring it's no surprise why
some investors are skeptical
standardizing ESG metrics is showing
some promise already
instead of incentivizing investors to
cherry pick data that makes companies
look good they encourage us to measure
what matters
for example data security is massively
important for healthcare companies
because patient Safety and Security are
Paramount
although important data security might
not be as Central a consideration for
say a kitchen cabinet manufacturer
there's a cool Harvard Business School
study that was released not too long ago
and it found that companies that address
material ESG issues can outperform
companies that don't buy as much as nine
percent per year
that's good news hashtag can't stop
won't stop
here's a second solution
investors like me are working on
literally changing the way we calculate
Financial forecasts so right now
most investors use
Financial models to make educated
predictions about what a company might
do in the future and how much money it's
going to make let's just say we also
excel at making spreadsheets
I'm so thrilled more than zero people
laughed at that one
[Laughter]
what if though what if in addition to
basic financial data we built in other
pieces of data into our models that are
predictive of how much earnings a
company is going to make
but beyond standardiz geometrics or new
ways of calculating Financial forecasts
I think the third and most important
thing we need is Trust
if we trust and expect that companies
that do good will be around longer we
start to create a future where ESG
becomes an indelible part of any company
we start to create a future where
sustainable companies are less risky to
own and money managers believe in using
the right data to make better decisions
we start to create a world where you the
personal investor Leverage The Power of
expectations to demand even more tools
even better metrics and so on and so
forth where trust in the system improves
further economists might call this a
virtuous cycle
I sometimes call this The Virtuous cycle
of how to keep Humanity alive for
centuries and eons to come yay awesome
but that might be a little too long so
for short let's call it the virtuous
cycle of investing in the 21st century
because like it or not it represents the
future of investing
if there's one thing to take away from
what I've been saying it's this
fellow Millennials and genziers start
thinking about your assets today start
thinking about your savings what might
be passed down to you and how it can be
used to build the world's future
if you don't invest your own money
ask your fund manager what they plan to
do with your assets what metrics they
use and why
your Pension funds your 401k even the
money in your savings or checkings
account all can be put to work to create
The Virtuous cycle of investing in the
21st century
and if this sounds like a pie in the sky
idea right now think about Lord Kane's
mustache for a second and consider
whether it's your expectations that may
need changing
thank you
[Applause]